in just six short hours clark county
will once again be requiring mass be
worn
inside businesses vaccinated or not good
evening to you thanks for joining us at
six i'm brian loftis and i'm denise
valdez tonight business owners are
preparing to enforce those mask mandate
rules
victoria saha spoke to some who say
although they will comply with the rules
they're still scared to lose customers
that's it i like it
keep those shoulders straight it's a
packed gym at modem athletics clients
are taking full advantage of their last
workout without masks
it is not easy at the gym to wear your
mask it is extremely difficult
especially for myself you know young
ones who have to do it
i mean you know it gets very sweaty it
makes it very difficult to breathe and
stuff like that you're honestly
bringing breathing in like a wet towel
knowing how uncomfortable it could get
wearing a mask while working out is
concerning for owner michael johnston
who says is scared fewer clients will
come in if things shut down i shut down
my business shuts down nothing happens
my family won't have the income that we
currently have at this point that we're
making through our
business running at this time johnston
says he understands wearing a mask
inside the gym isn't the most ideal
situation for his clients
but he's willing to give them a few more
breaks while they work out
over at sin city knits owner debbie
mccarty has her mask mandate sign up
i have all ages from six up to 86
you know that come in here i just want
everybody safe
even if it means the mask mandate turns
away customers
it's going to be a little bit harder to
keep my doors open you know
don't take a paycheck this month and
some vaccinated customers have some
words for those choosing to not get the
shot
stay home and stay away from the rest of
the people
victoria saha 8 news now the new
guidelines will override the county's
decision only require employees to mask
up
it is still not clear when the cdc will
make any possible changes to this denise